these are 52 facts about one piece that
you probably didn't know oda originally
planned for the series to only last for
five years with the main antagonist
being the emperors but his plans would
be extended mostly due to his creation
of the warlords of the sea the
supernovas who have now played pivotal
roles since their introduction were
actually a last minute addition to the
story they were created at sabori and
oda initially had no real plans for them
till he made them zorro is initially the
only member of the supernovas who
doesn't have a devil fruit this is
because killer ate a defective smile
fruit in wano which technically now
makes him a devil fruit user what we are
talking about zorro did you know that he
was initially going to be a bodyguard to
the one and only buggy the clown panda
man a non-canon easter egg character
appears in several parts of the manga
and has even made animated appearances
in some one-piece movies even though it
seems like a lot the events from the
moment luffy leaves to become a pirate
till the start of the time skip all took
place in a space of only four months
while the anime took around 12 years to
get to that point crocodile the
sichibukai who controlled alabasta
briefly thought luffy was using haki
during their fight he considered it by
saying could it be thanks to the manga
cover stories we would find out that mr
two survived his fight with magellan and
would go on to become the new queen of
level 5.5 where the okamas live and
party another interesting fact about mr
two or bon clay is that unlike the other
members of the baroque works he never
had a female partner and this was
because he identifies as both male and
female this next fact is only based on
the manga since they first met each
other there has never been a moment in
the story where zoro called sanji by his
name sanji created an alias called mr
prince during a small period in alabasta
and it would later be revealed that he
was in fact an actual prince during the
whole cake island arc sanji's origins
were also teased when he told the crew
he came from the north blue and it would
be revealed later on that it was indeed
where his place of origin the germa
kingdom was during the later parts of
dressrosa where a wanted list of all the
heroes was being shown we never see
conjuro and this was a great hint
showing that he was the mole amongst the
odin retainers well before his first
introduction at wano there was a brief
tease of the sun god nika during the
skypia arc in the scene while luffy was
dancing for a moment he resembled the
silhouette of nikka that was shown when
jinbe and who's who fought this was
meant to serve as a parallel of luffy
becoming the sun god which was further
hinted via the reveal of his devil fruit
true name minotomosan was a gag
background character created by oda to
fix the door that magically reappeared
just after higuma the bandit destroyed
it he is an incredibly skilled grumpy
short man who can't help but fix broken
doors just like manatomo-san and
pandaman another gag background
character created by oda is sam a
bald-headed drunk all three of them have
appeared across one piece media as quick
nods and easter eggs luffy once made a
weird sketch of a creature that shares
striking similarities to frankie before
frankie was even introduced to the story
jinbe planned to be a straw hat ever
since he met luffy but due to the world
changing after the events of marineford
he had to partner with the big mom
pirates for the sake of his people he
would eventually free himself from his
vow to her and join the straw hats
officially during the wano arc rooma the
legendary samurai of wano made his manga
debut way before the one-piece thriller
bark arc in oda's brief multi-chapter
series called wanted the rumors chapter
was called monsters and saw the journey
of a younger rumor wanting to be the
strongest warrior in the land the
original pitch for one piece was titled
romance dawn and released in the wanted
series it shared similar beats to one
piece but had differences like the
mentor figure to luffy not being shanks
fans of the series noticed that a lot of
the usop's lies would slowly turn out to
be true some examples of these lies
manifesting are tontara land existing
the huge mole with miss merry christmas
dragon on punk hazard cerberus on
thriller bark giant goldfish and more
way before their introduction at
dressrosa noland had visited tontatas
and it was mentioned during the skypia
flashbacks oda is very specific with his
chapter numbers and often plans out
certain chapters for big reveals for
instance gear 2 was introduced in
chapter 387 and gear 4 in chapter 783
while the one piece movies are usually
not canon we would get a specific piece
of canon info in film z during a bathtub
scene with the male straw hats aokiji
would interrupt them briefly and it
would be revealed that aside from his
scars he also lost his leg during the
battle with akainu at punk hazard this
is because logia users cannot regenerate
severely injured limbs did you know that
sanji was initially going to be called
naruto yeah that's right but due to the
success of kishimato's shonen series
called naruto he had to scrap the idea
all the marine admirals introduced in
the series including green bull were
based on famous japanese actors oda
loves films and that's why he based the
original three admirals on kuni tanaka
yasuko matsura and banta suguara who are
well known actors in japan besides the
marines other characters are based on
several popular real people too for
instance frankie's design mirrors that
of jim carrey and aceventura and ivankov
is based on frank n furter from rocky
horror show oda decided to give luffy
devil fruit that will grant him
rubber-like abilities because he wanted
the series to keep its wacky fun and
childlike energy no matter how serious
things got in the story brook talked
about hearing about a rookie by the name
of roger this was because he was already
a seasoned pirate years before roger
went out to sea with raylai well this
might sound surprising considering the
story of one piece primarily focuses on
the life and adventures of pirates no
pirate in the story makes use of an eye
patch however oda confirmed that a
pirate with an eye patch would appear at
the end of the series so all fans should
make sure they keep their eyes peeled
open for that towards the final chapters
oda's story of one piece is very
original but he also does a lot of
research and is very fascinated by
things like films books and history
that's why characters like blackbeard
jewelry bonnie and alvida are all based
on real-life pirates two of the gorosei
share striking facial similarities to
two very popular men namely mahatma
gandhi and mikhail gorbachev the milk
maiden who gets saved from blackbeard's
minions by the revolutionary army during
the reverie arc actually made her first
appearance a long time before that she
appeared exclusively on the manga cover
page which showed her hanging out with
ace the revolutionary army ship is
called the wind grandma which is based
off the grandma a real-life yacht used
to transport 82 cuban combatants who in
the 1950s planned to overthrow fulgencio
batista from his place of power oda
shares a birthday with port gus d ace
and the date is december 31st new year's
eve oda has publicly admitted that the
hardest characters for him to draw on
the story are shirahoshi and boa hancock
dragon leader of the revolutionary seems
to mostly lack the childlike personality
that luffy and garp possess however he
does happen to share something else with
them just like his other family members
he does have a mark on the left part of
his face via his special tattoos robin
and usop are the crew members in charge
of giving haircuts amongst the straw
hats sabo the revolutionary and
long-lost brother of luffy would turn
out to have the same design as a
character in the manga that was shown in
a crowd way back at the log town during
luffy's planned execution by buggy this
has never been officially confirmed but
due to sabo's temporal amnesia at the
time and dragon's presence at low town
it makes a lot of sense another
interesting bit of low town was
lightning that interrupted the execution
and hit buggy this lightning was most
likely created by the leader of the
revolutionaries and luffy's father
dragon he was present at low town during
that time and even had a brief
altercation with smoker nami is the
third smartest character to come out of
east blue with only ben beckham and
captain kuro being smarter than her this
was officially stated by oda himself
usopp's birthday is on april 1st and
it's extremely fitting because that's
the april fool's day and he's a very
good liar oda initially planned for
goldie rogers iconic facial hair to
actually be nasal hair but thankfully
that idea was changed oda stated that
akainu's devil fruit has the strongest
defensive power and that he'd probably
get to the one piece quickly if he went
out to search for it this coupled with
his extremely heated personality is why
he's arguably the most dangerous admiral
in the story law's devil fruit is so
important that the world government
would be willing to pay 5 billion
berries for it in his original design
chopper was actually drawn as a weird
reindeer zebra hybrid who had a very big
interest in smoking cigarettes oda's
editor shimizu has publicly stated that
while the end of marine fort and ace's
storyline resonated with a lot of fans
the ending of one piece itself will be
much more touching than that part of the
story whitebeard edward newgate and
blackbeard marshall d teach share the
first and last name of the real-life
blackbeard whose name was edward teach
oda has stated that if he could get any
devil fruit from the series it would be
robbins since it would allow him to draw
faster oda's wife jiaki inaba happened
to be a one-piece fan and he saw her
while she performed on stage as nami the
cat burglar click on this video where we
explained all luffy's forms in one piece
go on click it